logan webb on the hill tonight for the
giants take a look at what he has done
this year 22 stars 10-3
with a 2-8-0 era
and for logan webb that kind of tells
you half the story because when you look
at what he's done at home he's 5-0
in 10 games with an era of 1.66
and a swinging strike three changed up
in the dirt and posey throws out albies
one away
struck him out with a slider
two straight strikeouts to start the
night
and he beat the shift
so there goes the no hitter in the first
inning a two out single for the
incomparable freddy freeman
instead he shoots this one into shallow
right that's going to drop in for a base
hit lamont wade
couldn't catch that and the braves have
back to back two out singles
well beautiful approach and that brings
up the league leader in rbis adam duvall
with 101 of them
driven toward right weight on the run
that's headed for the corner that's down
it's in the corner that's going to score
one streaking around riley he's coming
to the plate the throw is late adam
duvall does it again a double it's two
nothing atlanta and all of this with two
outs
struck him out looking but
the giants
are going to have to come from behind
two-nothing atlanta
well after two starts in a row with no
strikeouts chip last friday versus
marlins ian anderson had a stuff
two walks to nine strikeouts 21 swings
and misses most vibrate starter you see
since 18.
brandon belt 25 home runs for the year
that ball is hammered deep to right
field adios
brandon belt hits a rocket to tie this
game
the guy who caught the ball
has a branded belt
captain patch on his music
duct tape seat on his chest
oh yeah good for you pal brandon belts
26 home run of the year man is he
swinging the bad well
did posey go yes he did
tripp gibson rings him up and that's
anderson's first out one away
and bryant lifts this one toward right
and that'll be playable for solaire and
that will retire the side elite off walk
and a belt homer ties the game it's 2-2
heading to the second he had 3 21
for atlanta became their everyday
catcher
right in their strikes recall
that's just movement he gave up on
beautiful backdoor sinker
nobody can figure it out in the second
half he is right at the ship
strikeout number five
a shutdown inning there for logan webb
crawford longoria the stella coming up
the giants with a 2-2 tie as they come
to bat with crawford coming up
left field
deep
it is good a home run
to the opposite field by brandon
crawford
and the giants take the lead
21st home run of the year for brandon
crawford that boy just took off
that's where you get pushed when you hit
a high fly ball
the ground winds coming into the hitter
but the high wind is blowing out
how do you do that i'm just trying to
hit the ball
well you watch him day in and day out he
could do it
headed to the shortstop and crawford to
le stella for the force out on freeman
inning over
little chopper slowly hit riley barehand
fires to first and god and by a quarter
step
anybody faster and that's probably an
infield hit and credit to riley he never
gave up on that play
and made an excellent grab and throw to
get the first out
he pokes it past bell
inside out swing heading for third is
rosario the throw cut off and
everybody's safe they're at first and
third
more two-out magic for the braves
2-2
got him swinging
so the strikeout for logan webb braves
threatened do not score wade bryant
crawford coming up when we come back
on this beautiful friday in san
francisco the giants leading the braves
three to two as wade hits a high drive
deep right field this one is headed for
the cove it is out into the water lavon
way junior
a splash home run the second time he's
done that the giants lead us four to two
that's three home runs tonight for the
giants
as this one caught on a dive great play
by dansby swanson
a full layout and a dive retires bryant
beautifully done
one out that infield defense showing off
most athletic
infield defense and all the baseball
that was up
that is whacked into the right center
field gap
crawford with the turnaround second he's
going to try for three here comes the
throw and
they got it
i don't know if they got him at first
but great job by austin coming back to
put the tag down
and a break for the braves
crawford got greedy tried for a triple
the braves nailed him for the second out
got him with the slider
strikeout number seven
i think mike last year he would have
been rattled by a strike zone like this
totally two down the 1-1 pitch on the
ground toward third longoria is gonna
toss it over to first and logan webb
retires the top of the order in order
giants to the bottom of the fifth take a
4-2 lead
in the number six logan webb back in the
hill he's got the one he wants
on the ground one hop diving crawford
gets up and he throws him out what a
play
that's 110 miles an hour laid out
completely prone to the ground to a hot
backhander
and then gets up and rifles a bullet
over
and it's not even close
he got him to chase that is the eighth
strikeout for logan webb
and that is all for swanson well you
saved that change up for a two-strike
surprise a lot of sliders in the at-bat
ninth strikeout
and he's hit three pinch at home runs
but this one will stay in the yard rough
three up three down
and maybe the end of the night he's at
101 pitches logan webb another beauty
two on one out and here is travis darno
who's looking for his first hit
high fly ball to left did he get enough
at the wall
he did
darneau hits a three-run homer and the
braves have taken the lead in the ninth
unb
believable
and the giants are down to their final
out two and two with two down in the
ninth
deep to left field down the line
down to their final strike
and donovan salado launches one into the
tunnel
it's tied up
here's the 2-0 that is hit to
left-center field going back onto duggar
and he will make the catch on the run
and then slam into the wall
steven duggar what a play just into the
game
the braves go to their bullpen once
again for
jacob
webb pick off throne he throws it wildly
crawford gets up and will head to third
and that changes a lot
a high fly ball
peterson backs up crawford is tagging
and crawford is coming here comes the
throw and
tweet
it is kevin gausman
who wins the game
unbelievable just the way we thought it
would turn out